TAPPER IN CNN TONIGHT.
>>> WELCOME TO CNN TONIGHT.
I'M JAKE TAPPER.
WE'RE JUST ONE WEEK AWAY FROM
THE MIDTERM ELECTIONS.
ONE WEEK.
ONE KEY ISSUES FOR VOTERS IS NOW
SURGING TO THE FRONT OF THE PACK
OF ISSUES.
AND THAT ISSUE IS CRIME.
TONIGHT WE'RE GOING TO TRY TO
EXPLAIN WHY THIS ISSUE SEEMS TO
BE RESONATING WITH SO MANY
VOTERS.
AND WE'LL INVESTIGATE WHETHER
THE PERCEPTION OF RISING CRIME
MATCHES REALITY.
LET'S BEGIN BY EXAMINING THIS
THROUGH THE LENS OF ONE
PARTICULAR HIGH PROFILE ASSAULT.
DAVID DEPAPE, THE MAN ACCUSED OF
ATTACKING PAUL PELOSI LAST WEEK.
HE ENTERED NOT GUILTY DURING HIS
INITIAL COURT APPEARANCE.
ACCORDING TO THE ASSAILANT'S OWN
WORDS, DEPAPE'S MAIN TARGET WAS
NANCY PELOSI.
A SHARER OF FAR RIGHT CONSPIRACY
THEORIES.
DEPAPE ALLEGEDLY WANTED TO BREAK
HER KNEE CAPS WITH A HAMMER.
>> THERE'S ALSO BEEN A LOT OF
SPECULATION REGARDING MR.
DEPAPE'S VULNERABILITY TO -- TO,
UM -- MISINFORMATION.
>> NOW THIS STORY IS ONE ABOUT
MISINFORMATION.
ABOUT THE RISKS OF DERANGED
CONSPIRACY THEORIES AND
DEHUMANIZING POLITICAL RHETORIC.
BUT THIS IS ALSO A STORY ABOUT
CRIME.
IT'S A STORY ABOUT A DERANGED
PERSON BREAKING INTO THE HOME OF
A WOMAN HE SOUGHT TO HARM AND
ATTACKING HER HUSBAND.
THE NOTION THAT VIOLENT CRIME IS
ON THE RISE HAS LEFT MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS SCARED.
AND THE GOP HAS TRIED TO HARNESS
THE POWER OF THAT FEAR.
TOP REPUBLICANS CONDEMNED THE
PELOSI ATTACK.
THEY DISPUTED THAT RHETORIC
POINTED ANY ROLE AND INSTEAD,
POINTED AT THE ISSUE OF RISING
CRIME RATES.
>> IF THIS WEREN'T PAUL PELOSI,
THIS CRIMINAL WOULD PROBABLY BE
ON THE STREETS TOMORROW.
THIS IS WHAT DEMOCRATIC POLICIES
ARE BRINGING.
>> IT'S A POTENT ISSUE THAT
DEMOCRATS HAVE TOLD ME ARE USED
AGAINST
MORE THAN $98 MILLION THIS
ELECTION CYCLE HAS BEEN FOCUSED
BY REPUBLICANS IN ADS ATTACKING
DEMOCRATS ON CRIME.
THAT'S ABOUT $22 MILLION MORE
THAN REPUBLICANS SPENT ON ADS
ATTACKING DEMOCRATS ON
INFLATION.
EACH AD, OF COURSE, MAKING THE
CASE IN 30-SECOND SOUND BITES
THAT DEMOCRATIC POLICIES ON
CRIME MAKE US ALL LESS SAFE.
>> TAKE IT FROM US, MANDELA
BARNES POLICIES ARE A THREAT TO
YOUR FAMILY.
>> BARNES WANTS TO DEFUND OUR
POLICE.
>> VIOLENT CRIME TERRORIZING NEW
YORK.
BUT WHILE POLICE FIGHT TO PUT
CRIMINALS BEHIND BARS, SHAUN
PATRICK MELONY FOUGHT TO KEEP
THEM OUT.
>> EVERY ONE OF THOSE ADS CAN
AND SHOULD BE FACT CHECKED.
BUT THE BIGGER QUESTION FOR US
IS THIS, IS LIFE IN AMERICA
ACTUALLY MORE DANGEROUS THAN IT
USED TO BE?
HERE'S WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT CRIME
AT THE NATIONAL LEVEL.
AFTER YEARS OF DECLINE, NATIONAL
RATES OF VIOLENT CRIME DID RISE
DURING THE COVID-19 PANDEMIC.
BETWEEN 2019 AND 2020, THE TRUMP
YEARS, THE U.S. HOMICIDE RATE
ROSE ABOUT 30%.
THAT'S THE HIGHEST INCREASE
RECORDED IN MODERN HISTORY.
THEN IN 2021, DURING BIDEN, THE
CRIME RATE ROSE 3%.
THE OVERALL VIOLENT RATE, NOT
COUNTING HOMICIDES, ALL VIOLENT
CRIME, THAT DECLINED BY 1%
NATIONALLY ACCORDING TO THE FBI.
SO NATIONALLY IT APPEARS
HOMICIDES ARE UP.
THE OVERALL VIOLENT CRIME RATE
IS SLIGHTLY DOWN.
REGIONALLY, THOUGH, WHERE YOU
LIVE, WELL THAT'S A MIXED BAG.
TAKE OKLAHOMA WHERE THE
DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATE FOR
GOVERNOR, JOY HOFMEISTER, SHE'S
THE ONE RUNNING AGAINST KEVIN
STITT ON THE ISSUE OF CRIME.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT THE FACTS.
THE FACT IS THE RATES OF VIOLENT
CRIME ARE HIGHER IN OKLAHOMA --
>> IT'S NOT TRUE.
>> IN YOUR WATCH THAN IN NEW
YORK AND CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S A FACT.
>> WE'LL HAVE THAT FACT CHECKED
BY THE FRONTIER, SUPERINTENDENT.
>> HOFMEISTER WAS MOCKED AND
EVEN QUESTIONED BY THE
MODERATOR.
BUT WHEN THE OKLAHOMA NEWSPAPER
FACT CHECKED HER, SHE WAS RIGHT.
THE MAJOR CITIES CHIEFS
ASSOCIATIONS SAYS IN THE FIRST
SIX MONTHS OF THIS YEAR,
ROBBERIES AND AGGRAVATED
ASSAULTS INCREASED IN CITIES OF
MORE THAN 500,000 PEOPLE.
BUT THIS IS WHERE STATISTICS CAN
OFTEN BE USED TO MAKE WHATEVER
POINT YOU WANT TO MAKE.
THE MAJOR CITY CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION SAYS MURDERS ARE
DOWN IN AGGREGATE IN THE 70
URBAN AREAS THEY LOOKED AT.
BUT FOR 30 OF THOSE 70, MURDERS
ARE UP.
AND THOSE INCLUDE ATLANTA.
THERE ARE BIG RACES IN GEORGIA
RIGHT NOW.
AND DENVER, BIG RACES IN
COLORADO.
MILWAUKEE, GOVERNOR AND SENATE
SEATS ON THE LINE IN WISCONSIN.
WHEN CRIME RATES GO UP, LOCAL
PROSECUTORS PUSHING CRIMINAL
JUSTICE POLICIES, THEY OFTEN GET
BLAMED.
IS THAT FAIR?
IT'S USUALLY A LOT MORE
COMPLICATED THAN THAT.
TAKE BOSTON WHERE THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY STOPPED PROSECUTING
NON-VIOLENT OFFENSES.
WHAT HAPPENED THERE?
VIOLENT CRIME DECREASED BY 15%
IN 2021.
AND TAKE TWO CITIES THAT
INCREASED THEIR POLICE BUDGETS.
INDIANAPOLIS, INDIANA, AND
MOBILE, ALABAMA.
THEY INCREASED THEIR POLICE
BUDGETS AND SAW AN INCREASE IN
VIOLENT CRIME LAST YEAR.
NOW LOOK, THE ECONOMY CLEARLY
RANKS AS THE TOP ISSUE FOR
VOTERS AS WE HEAD INTO THE
MIDTERM ELECTIONS IN ONE WEEK.
BUT IN THE LATEST POLLING FROM
CBS NEWS AND UGOV, 65% OF YOU
SAID THE ISSUE OF CRIME WILL BE
VERY IMPORTANT TO YOUR VOTE.
A SEPARATE POLL RELEASED BY
GALLOP LAST WEEK FINDS AMERICANS
ARE MORE LIKELY NOW THAN AT ANY
TIME OVER THE LAST FIVE DECADES
TO SAY THERE'S MORE CRIME IN
THEIR COMMUNITY THAN THERE WAS A
YEAR AGO.
56% OF YOU SAY THERE'S MORE
CRIME WHERE YOU LIVE NOW THAN
LAST YEAR.
56%.
AND THAT'S A TREND THAT'S BEEN
BUILDING OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS
SINCE 2020, WHEN JOE BIDEN WAS
ELECTED.
>> CRIME IS A BIG DARN DEAL.
>> IT USED TO BE ELSEWHERE.
BUT NOW IT'S IN OUR OWN NECK OF
THE WOODS.
>> WE WANT TO MOVE, YES, BECAUSE
OF CRIME.
WE WANT OUT.
>> WE LIVE IN AN AREA WHERE
THERE IS QUITE A BIT OF CRIME.
SO WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THAT.
>> OFTEN WHEN VOTERS OR
JOURNALISTS OR POLITICIANS BRING
UP THE ISSUE OF CRIME, YOU'LL
HEAR PROGRESSIVE PUNDITS
POINTING TO DATA THAT SHOWS
CRIME IS DOWN SINCE THE '90s,
WHICH IS TRUE.
OR SOME OF THE DATA -- I SAID IT
EARLIER TODAY -- SUGGESTING THAT
THIS ISSUE IS INVENTED BY
CONSERVATIVES TO SCARE THE
PUBLIC INTO VOTING FOR
REPUBLICANS.
NOT EVERYONE OUT THERE AGREES.
WHILE ACCORDING TO POUGH, ONLY A
THIRD OF WHITE DEMOCRATS, 81% OF
BLACK VOTERS IN GENERAL SAY
VIOLENT CRIME IS IMPORTANT TO
THEIR VOTES.
THERE'S ANOTHER IMPORTANT SET OF
NUMBERS FOR YOU TO KEEP IN MIND.
WHICH MIGHT EXPLAIN WHY
REPUBLICANS ARE TRYING TO
CAPITALIZE ON CRIME AS A
CAMPAIGN ISSUE RIGHT NOW.
IN THAT CBS POLL I JUST
MENTIONED, 46% OF YOU SAY
REPUBLICAN POLICIES WILL MAKE
YOU FEEL SAFER.
YOU MIGHT BE ABLE TO ATTRIBUTE
SOME OF THAT IMBALANCE, PROPS,
TO VOTERS DISTRUST OF DEMOCRATS
AFTER THE WHOLE DEFUND THE
POLICE CAMPAIGN.
THE MOVEMENT WAS EMBRACED BY
SOME DEMOCRATIC LAWMAKERS,
ESPECIALLY PROGRESSIVES.
>> I'VE TOTALLY OPPOSED TO
DEFUNDING THE POLICE OFFICERS.
>> IT'S NOT SURPRISING
REPUBLICANS MIGHT LEAN INTO THIS
DIVIDE AMONG DEMOCRATS.
TRAVEL WITH ME TO GEORGIA RIGHT
NOW WHERE REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR
BRIAN KEMP IS TRYING TO FIGHT
OFF A CHALLENGE FROM DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATE STACY ABRAMS.
IN A DEBATE TWO NIGHTS AGO --
>> MS. ABRAMS THAT HAS SAID SHE
WANTS TO DEFUND THE POLICE.
YOU GOTTA CHECK THE RECORD.
BECAUSE MS. ABRAMS ON CNN GOT
ASKED THE QUESTION WOULD SHE
DEFUND THE POLICE AND SHE SAID
YES.
>> FOR THE RECORD, ADRAMS TOLD
CNN IN 2020 YES IF NEED BE.
THOUGH SHE FOUND THE OVERALL
QUESTION A FALSE CHOICEMENT BUT
IS IT?
>>> TO THE WEST COAST NOW, TO
OREGON, DEMOCRATS HAVE
CONTROLLED THE GOVERNOR'S
MANSION THERE SINCE 1987.
BUT THAT COULD CHANGE.
PARTIALLY BECAUSE VOTERS ARE
UNHAPPY ABOUT CRIME RATES IN
PORTLAND.
WHERE WE'VE SEEN RIOTS AND
CRIME, FRANKLY, OUT OF CONTROL.
LIFE LONG DEMOCRAT JOE CORILLO
SAYS HE BARELY RECOGNIZES
OREGON.
YOU SEE THE HOMELESSNESS, PEOPLE
DYING ON THE STREETS FROM
OVERDOSES.
IT'S IN SHAMBLES RIGHT NOW.
THIS YEAR HE SAYS HE'S VOTING
FOR THE REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE FOR
GOVERNOR.
IN COLORADO, A STATE JOE BIDEN
CARRIED BY 13 POINTS.
REPUBLICANS SAY THEY SEE AN
OPENING TO UNSEAT DEMOCRATIC
SENATOR MICHAEL BENNETT.
AND RISING MAGA STAR RON
DESANTIS MENTIONS CRIME.
>> COLORADO NEEDS NEW
LEADERSHIP.
JOE'S FOCUSED ON BUILDING THE
WALL AND CRACKING DOWN ON CRIME.
>> WE'LL TALK TO O'DAY IN JUST A
MOMENT.
WHEN YOU WATCH POLITICAL TV ADS
ON CRIME, YOU MIGHT NOT EVEN
HEAR ANY REAL SOLUTIONS BEING
PROPOSED.
ONES THAT WILL MAKE A
DIFFERENCE.
BUT YOU ALSO MIND BE COMFORTED
TO HEAR SOMEONE OUT THERE EVEN
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT IT'S A
PROBLEM, THAT IT'S A FEAR.
ALL POLITICS ARE LOCAL, GOES THE
CLICHÉ.
AND WHEN IT COMES TO CRIME, THAT
IS ESPECIALLY TRUE.
LOCAL AS IN HERE.
YOUR PERSONAL EXPERIENCES MIGHT
NOT BE REFLECTED IN DATA IF YOU
DON'T FEEL SAFE.
IF YOU OR SOMEONE YOU CARE ABOUT
HAS BEEN ACCOSTED OR ASSAULTED,
THAT'S YOUR EXPERIENCE.
FEAR IS PRIMAL.
IT'S A CRUCIAL EMOTION.
IT MOBILIZES US TO RESPOND TO
LIFE OR DEATH SITUATIONS.
AVOIDING DANGER AT ALL COST.
YOU CAN HEAR THE DATA.
VIOLENT CRIME MIGHT BE DOWN IN
YOUR AREA.